mais bientôt c'est l'heure de parlements
et 2 45 minutes pour faire le tour de
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
avec kathia gilder à mes côtés bonjour
cassez bonjour michael et beaucoup
d'actualité encore cette semaine à moins
de trois semaines avant le premier tour
des élections départementales
le front national fait la course en tête
dans les sondages et du coup à l'ump le
ps crise pour les minis sont priés
d'aller sur de terreur pour faire
campagne
bref la campagne des départementales
proc un tournant nationale au sénat la
loi emblématique sur la transition
énergétique a été votée les écologistes
qui n'ont pas donné leur voix aux textes
il s'insurge notamment contre un retour
en force du nucléaire de son côté la
ministre ségolène royal promet donc
revenir à la version initiale de son
texte
et puis on ira faire un petit tour au
cinéma voir un film qui a obtenu un
oscar citizen fort un documentaire sur
edouard snowden savez celui qui a
déclenché des écoutes mondiale exercées
par les américains c'est l'autre plus de
l'hebdo saxo bank
notre invité jean marc germain bonjour
vous êtes députée socialiste des
hauts-de-seine ancien directeur de
cabinet de martine aubry tout avait si
bien commencé jean marc germain
c'est le titre de votre livre qui vient
de paraître aux éditions de l'atelier
journal d'un fraudeur vous revendiquer
l'appellation on en parlera tout à
l'heure avec notre chroniqueur jim
jarrassé mais pour commencer cette
émission je vous propose un état des
lieux du ps face à vous frondeur et bien
il ya les réformateurs qui s'organise en
vue du congrès prochainement un
reportage de jean baptiste daoulas ils
se surnomment les réformateurs et ils
veulent peser à trois mois du congrès
l'ailé droite du ps présenté hier sa
contribution sous le regard bienveillant
d'un proche de manuel valls
le secrétaire d'état jean marie le guen
sous l'autorité de jean marie nombre de
ministres enracinée s'il n'y avait pas
eu de consignes qu'aucun nice ne signale
aucune conclusion je voulais dire
combien nous étions engagés et agit face
aux frondeurs les réformateurs ont réuni
une quarantaine de parlementaires avec
l'objectif de convertir l'ensemble du ps
à la politique du gouvernement dans la
salle les militants demandent à l'ailé
gauche de s'adapter à la crise
économique
quelques jours après le vote de la loi
macron gérard collomb s'interrogent sur
le maintien des frondeurs au sein du ps
si un certain nombre de membres du parti
socialiste parce que c'est du côté de ré
cieux mélenchon et du côté de l'extrême
gauche que se trouve aujourd'hui la
vérité faut le dire clairement et à ce
moment là allez sur cette ligne avec
ceux qui sont sur la même pensée les
réformateurs font monter la pression
avant le congrès et lancent un ultimatum
au premier secrétaire du ps
c'est sûr que nous voulons poser sur que
si demain dans la motion de jean
christophe cambadélis
c'est martine aubry qui écrit là contre
la motion est que nous ne sommes pas
nous ne tenons pas la plus c'est sûr
qu'il y aura des difficultés
le ps reste tiraillé entre deux lignes
de plus en plus opposées le
rassemblement du parti s'annonce d'ores
et déjà compliquée jean marc chers
malades de ligne opposée et en même
temps on a entendu les arts colons qui
est certain qu'ils espèrent vous
convertir à la politique du gouvernement
c'est un peu inconvenant je crois qu'il
faut accepter le débat et pas comme le
fait gérard collomb dans votre reportage
de dire que certains devraient quitter
le parti socialiste qui fait la force
d'une formation politique c'est de
cesser d'être nombreux freins et le pôle
des réformateurs
c'est un tout petit paul qui d'ailleurs
incarne une ligne qui quand il ya eu un
scrutin que c'était celle de manuel
valls a pesé 5%
si je me
on est des voies non de la loi macro et
java on a même entendu pour nous le
rookie à un moment donné a dit messi
sont pas contents qu'elle s'en aille oui
mais ça il faut éviter vraiment parce
qu'on a on a des débats qui sont
compliqués je prends la sphère du
travail du dimanche
personne ne peut prétendre que c'est
simple d'un côté ça favorise la vie des
consommateurs vous comme on est très
content le dimanche après-midi de
pouvoir aller dans un magasin de
bricolage quand on en a besoin et en
même temps quand on réfléchit à ce que
ça comme conséquence mais moi quand je
réfléchis aux travailleurs les plus
fragiles qui vont devoir être obligé
travail le dimanche parce que le choix
ça n'existe pas quand il ya cinq
millions de chômeurs le patron il vous
demande de venir travailler dimanche
vous allez travail dimanche parce que
sinon vous avez peur d'être le prochain
sur la liste des licenciés et quand on
voit aussi les conséquences sur les
territoires ça risque de faire
disparaître un certain nombre de petits
commerces
alors on se dit que le débat est
compliqué vous n'en aviez bas vous êtes
un fraudeur peut-on mesurer
oui oui on m'appelait un fondeur adoucis
ces derniers temps mais moi je vais un
peu d'eau dans votre nom en tout cas
depuis le début
j'essaye de débattre sur le fond ne pas
justement se mettre dedans vous devez
partir ou vous n'êtes pas des vrais
socialistes c'est pas ça le sujet c'est
que quand on a des différences il faut
en débattre et vous savez les français
à quand un débat on y vient les bulles
sondage sur les fondeurs oui j'ai vu
alors 55% vous trouve une bonne opinion
sur les frondeurs 65% on trouve normal
que vous opposez c'est votre victoire
en tout cas ça fait plaisir moi je me
fixe pas je me détermine pas en fonction
des sondages on avait eu d un peu moins
bon avant mais par contre je ressens
vraiment ça sur le terrain c'est j'étais
encore samedi à distribuer des tracts
pour soutenir les candidats aux
élections départementales
c'est ce que me disent les gens et je
raconte d'ailleurs au début de mon livre
je commence par récuser un peu ce terme
de frondeurs parce que moi j'ai eu
l'impression de faire tout simplement
mon travail de député
quand je suis d'accord finalement vous
l'accepter quand je suis d'accord je
vote
mais quand je suis pas d'accord je le
dis pendant deux ans je le dis puis je
fini par voter comme le demande le
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
ou président de la république
et puis au bout d'eux
nuance est plus possible parce que sinon
il n'y a plus de parlement mais les gens
qu'est ce qu'ils me disent ils me disent
merci après m'avoir dire vous êtes un
frondeur on vous a vu à la télé et me
disent merci pourquoi parce qu'à partir
du moment où je suis libre et bien ivre
il considère que je suis l'un des leurs
je suis pas là pour faire car pour cela
que le président de la république va
vous recevoir
oui et c'est une très bonne chose vous
savez donc mois offerts besoin de cette
idée qu'il avait lancée dans sa campagne
présidentielle de dire je recevrai
jamais les parlementaires ça me paraît
pas une bonne idée parce qu'il faut
prendre acte du fait que c'est lui qui
décide des lois dans notre pays il est
donc il faut qu'ils aient des contacts
avec les parlementaires dans différentes
de rendez-vous il rentre ce soir le club
le rendez vous aura lieu quand ben vous
verrez quand il aura eu lieu
je crois qu s'il faut que qu'est ce que
vous lui direz non mais je vous répond
pas à votre question de campagne c'est
bien qu'on ait pas non mais je vous
explique pourquoi parce que sinon ceux
qui nous écoutent vont dire pourquoi ne
le dis pas parce que je crois que c'est
important que ce rendez vous soit pas
une mise en scène ni du président de la
république qui montrent qu'ils allaient
aller coûte ni des frondeurs qui monte
qui pèse quelque chose mais un moment
utile de discussions et de compréhension
moi aussi j'ai écrit ce livre c'est
aussi pour que calmement en couchant sur
le papier un autre démarche chacun
puisse comprendre ce qu'on une
indication c'est avant les élections ou
après ça aura lieu dans les arbres et
qui viennent dans les jours qui viennent
oui donc certainement avant les
élections message important aussi
adressé à l'opinion
oui oui et c'est très bien que le
président de la république soient à
l'écouté de tous les parlementaires pas
simplement de ceux qui nous représentent
institutionnellement qui sont importants
du président de groupe le premier
secrétaire mais comme il le fait
d'ailleurs il reçoit des groupes
différents de parlementaires à la il
voulait voir entendre de lui même à
mieux que ce qu'on dit même si je
raconte dans le livre que moi je n'ai vu
au mois de juin en tête à tête
d'autres rendez vous aura lieu à
l'église et ses lacets essai collectif
sera sort a lieu un endroit que
que nous ne rendrons pas publique on
sera pas plus pour l'instant non mais
c'est pas important l'important que ces
lieux c'est qu'on discute et on va
discuter de quoi non ce rendez vous
c'est qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour le
pays
nous notre souhait est mon dernier
chapitre ça s'appelle il n'est pas trop
tard pour réussir c'est comment on fait
pour réussir les deux dernières années
du quinquennat parce que notre
conviction c'est que si françois
hollande ne réussit pas personne ne
réussira aucun socialiste ni manuel
valls ni les frondeurs ni gérard collomb
nini d'autres et la france ne réussira
pas non elle va passer un peu occupe
toute l'actualité de la semaine et va
commencer par le lundi c'est normal et
les élections approchent la droite la
gauche se mobilise pour lutter contre le
vote du front national mais une autre
donnée majeure arrive avec ce scrutin
c'est le risque de l'abstention vois ça
avec cécile seksu vous savez qu'il ya
des élections bientôt céder sélection du
quoi tient là mais franchement les
danses
les élections départementales n'attire
pas les foules
un français sur trois ne seraient pas au
courant que les 22 et 29 mars prochains
ils sont invités à aller voter pour
élire leurs conseillers départementaux
la cause selon xavier chinaud expert
électoral
c'est une vraie méconnaissance de cette
élection une espèce d'usiné à gaz un peu
complexe on élit des binômes parité avec
dix suppléants
c'est pas très clair pour les gens on a
changé la taille des cantons il a divisé
par deux ce qui fait que les cantons
sont plus gros donc quand il y avait un
fait local s'il faut on connaissait son
conseiller général parce qu'il est le
maire d'une grande commune
il ya une partie du canton on ne va plus
le connaître donc ça va atténuer l'effet
votre local au profit du vote national
conséquence 57% des français n'aurait
pas l'intention d'aller voter
une abstention qui pourrait faire le
bonheur du fn selon un sondage au doxa
le parti de marine le pen souhaite en
tête avec 33% des suffrages devant l'ump
et le ps
ça signifie qu'au soir du premier tour
dans la plupart des cantons france eh
bien on verra plus souvent des duels
entre l'ump et le front national que des
duels habituelle gauche/droite
ça signifie ça préfigure aussi
probablement une victoire de la droite
au second tour dans un maximum de
département et en même temps de gros
problèmes pour nicolas sarkozy et l'ump
sur les arbitrages qui auront lieu dans
l'entre-deux-tours le niveau de
l'abstention sera donc déterminant pour
l'accession au deuxième tour
en effet les règles électorales sont
strictes il faudra obtenir plus de 12 5%
des électeurs inscrits pour y parvenir
la crainte ce que au premier tour votre
électorat ne se déplace pas et du coup
vous perdez pas les 500 canton voire
1000 canton si les patients pronostic
est aussi quelques chiffres
oui c'est un peu ce qui s'est passé aux
municipales donc maintenant c'est
étrange mais il ya je crois papier en
fait le climat est un peu meilleure
parce qu'il ya il ya eu d'abord la très
bonne gestion par le président de la
république des attentats de paris et
montrouge et sa une une église de
peugeot sa et nous disent il ya les
indicateurs économiques c'est des rayons
de soleil on ne peut pas croire sur le
terrain que
tout et tout est réglé mais quand même
ça va mieux vraiment mieux il ya des
perspectives c'est encore mieux avec le
prix du pétrole avec les taux d'intérêt
donc on sent quand même sur le terrain
ce premier élément et deuxièmement il ya
un peu plus de concentration vers le
parti socialiste à gauche donc y aura
sans doute un peu moins de dispersion je
crois que les français ont compris qu'on
avait fait tout ce qu'on pouvait pour
avoir des listes uniques même si on a
piqué mais j'aimerais simplement un
communiqué compliqué oui c'est compliqué
et puis après parce que je souhaite
ce que je souhaite comment on fait pour
mobiliser les électeurs en parlant des
élections départementales on voit bien
que c'est pas le front national le
présent l'ancien président de la
république en parlant de fn/ps essaye de
stigmatiser fin de de faire l'enjeu
autour du front national enfin moi j'ai
vu que les ministres sur le terrain vous
devez payer les meetings trouve que le
fêtard et digne d'un ancien président de
la république
on va y venir ces fonds devraient venir
mais vous met de la partie des sionistes
de nationaliser cette conduite nous on
doit faire ça non mais c'est que les que
les ministres fassent campagne parce que
c'est des personnalités connues des
français c'est très bien mais regardez
ce qu'ils font
regardez la conférence de presse hier
dans notre premier secrétaire il a parlé
pendant les trois quarts de son
intervention de l'enjeu des
départementales parce que vous savez ce
qu'il faut que les français se disent au
moment de mettre le bulletin dans l'urne
et avant ça au moment d'y aller ou pas
c'est de se dire en qui j'ai le plus
confiance
quand il s'agira de se défendre un
enfant handicapé
une personne âgée ou les collèges un
socialiste un ump ou un front national
et s'ils se pose cette question
à chaque fois ils nous disent nous on
savent on sait que vous êtes là qu'on a
quand on a besoin de vous dans vos
permanence et dans les conseils généraux
pour nous défendre
que vous soyez dans la majorité
l'opposition c'est vrai mais au delà des
personnes entre l'étiquette politique
est aussi le fond de ce surcoût rang
vote les départementales comment est ce
que vous pouvez convaincre les français
d'aller voter pour une réforme qu'on
présente comme étant des élections
essentielles alors même que les
compétences des départements ne sont pas
encore clairement fixée parce que la loi
n'est pas votée on a tardé sur ce sujet
là mais maintenant les choses sont
claires
les transports ont été transférés à la
région le rsa ça va au département et
ensuite sur un processus un peu au cas
par cas qui permettra de transférer
d'autres compétences quand les élus le
décideront soit vers les métropoles soit
vers les régions donc les choses sont
claires il ya des départements ils
gardent des compétences très fort
maintenant faut voter pour ce que vous
considérez le plus à même de porter les
politiques de solidarité moi c'est le
seul message que j'ai fait un passage
électeurs bien compris alors mardi
justement d'en parler il beaucoup de
réactions à l'assemblée après ces fameux
propos on vous parlait de nicolas
sarkozy voté au premier tour pour le fn
c'est faire gagner la gauche au second
dixit nicolas sarkozy selon lui c'est le
fn ps
et bien cette formule a fait beaucoup
réagir elle est socialiste dénonce une
manoeuvre politicienne de l'ump avant
les élections et les abers tholonet un
fn en tête des suffrages c'est ce qui
pourrait se passer aux prochaines
élections départementales
selon plusieurs sondages le front
national pourrait obtenir jusqu'à 33%
des voix pour la droite ce score du
parti d'extrême droite n'a qu'une seule
explication
et nous constatons aujourd'hui que c'est
le parti socialiste qui cherche une
bouée de sauvetage dans la montée du
front national pour se maintenir au
pouvoir
mais je crois qu'il va se reprendre le
boomerang dans la figure puisque
désormais le parti socialiste risque de
sortir du jeu depuis la présidence de
françois mitterrand
la droite accuse le ps de favoriser la
montée du front national
hier dans une interview au figaro
nicolas sarkozy utilise et même la
formule fn ps
une manière de renvoyer les deux parties
dos à dos une position qualifiée de
slogans par le président du groupe
socialiste nicolas sarkozy essaye de
trouver des slogans pour cacher le
manque d'idées et ce n'est pas bon pour
la démocratie à ce n'est pas avec des
slogans que l'on arrive à résoudre la
chose quand on plus le principal
problème c'est bien la porosité
aujourd'hui entre l'électorat de droite
et l'électorat du front national
selon un récent sondage 19 % des
électeurs
ayant voté pour nicolas sarkozy au
premier tour de la présidentielle en
2012 souhaite la victoire du front
national au départemental alors votre
commentaire sur cette formule fn/ps
maladresse formule sans intérêt ou bien
erreur politique
je trouve que dans la bouche d'un ancien
président de la république c'est très
grave parce que au fond depuis des
décennies la gauche et la droite ont
partagé ensemble la république la
république c'est quoi c'est l'idée du
vivre ensemble
face à un parti le front national qui
stigmatisent l'étranger qui veut sortir
de l'europe qui défend le rétablissement
de la peine de mort qui maintenant
inscrite dans la constitution de notre
république
donc c'est un mail à grave pour vous
c'est là ils brisent ça jean françois
copé l'avait fait mais enfin c'était pas
la dimension politique le président du
lille osc quelque chose d'assez loin
pour que ça regroupe 10 dans le débat
voilà oui mais quand on est une
personnalité de cette dimension quand on
a incarné la france n'a pas le droit de
faire ça on doit parler de ses idées et
moi j'ai lu dans le figaro un certain
vide et j'étais un peu déçu d'ailleurs
c'était celle de 2007 qui reviennent
cette fois
voilà qui refusait totalement date est
enfin sigma ti zef a stigmatisé
s'attaquer à la fonction publique c'est
tout y passe la suppression des grilles
de rémunération cdd de cinq ans à la
place des emplois augmentation du temps
de travail en fin il a une espèce
d'obsession non remplacement d'un
fonctionnaire sur deux dans l'est
notamment dans la vie locale
fa c'est de la folie qu est ce qui fait
la force de la france ces services
publics moi je suis responsable de
l'assemblée
reste que vous êtes au parti socialiste
tout le monde me dit vous avez une
chance le vôtre trésor c'est vos
services publics c'est vos collectivités
locales élus nous programme une casse de
ça et puis toutes ces propositions il
n'y en a pas une de nouvelles moi je
suis assez critique sur un certain
nombre d'économies qui sont faites par
le gouvernement les fameux 50 milliards
même si je pense qu'il faut être sérieux
il faut réduire les déficits mais lui
c'est pas 50 qui proposent ces 150
milliard et j'ai pas si vous avez noté
mais sur quoi ils insistent les
politiques de formation professionnelle
la formation c'est la compétitivité de
demain et le logement après
les attentats et tout ce que ça a révélé
de malaise dans les banlieues dont le
logement est une des clés la mixité
sociale aussi donc il a des réponses non
seulement date et il sait pas du tout
renouveler mais en plus qui sont
dangereuses pour le pays si elles
devaient être mises en oeuvre donc moi
ça me non seulement je trouve qu'il se
comporte mal très franchement j'espère
que il va quitter cela parce que c'est
détestable
les français ont besoin de repères
républicain le premier ministre et
président de la république l'ont rappelé
admirablement en ce mois de janvier
et puis deuxièmement là on a un débat
politique
le phenom les réseaux câble c'est des
idées différentes et moi je respecte les
siennes et je les critiques avec alien
et jean marc gales va nous partons au
sénat cette fois avec une loi phare du
gouvernement qui a été vidée de sa
substance le texte la transition
énergétique il a été largement remanié
au sénat où assa avec laurent sauvage
c'est une coquille vide ou presque
la loi sur la transition énergétique a
été vidé de sa substance
après son passage au sénat la chambre
haute a supprimé l'objectif de 2025 pour
réduire la part du nucléaire à 50% dans
la production d'électricité
je suis un peu déçu parce que pour nous
c'est un point d'achoppement
et c'est d'ailleurs parce que cette
disposition a été adoptée que j'étais
contraint je dis bien la mort dans l'âme
de demander à ce que nous obtenions
autre ajout du sénat la capacité
maximale de la production d'électricité
d'origine nucléaire est augmentée alors
même que le gouvernement voulait la
plafonner à 63,2 gigawatts
tous les écologistes qui ont voté contre
le texte la loi sur la transition
énergétique est un retour au tout
nucléaire
cette loi n'est pas crédible celle loi
qui est une loi de transition
énergétique fait tout pour maintenir le
mix énergétique électrique français tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui
ce qui n'a aucun sens y compris dans le
contexte économique européen
donc voilà donc donc c'est un peu là
dessus un baroud d'honneur aussi du cdh
à deux de la majorité ump qu'il ne
pouvait pas à ne pas combattre cet
aspect du texte en commission mixte
paritaire députés et sénateurs vont
devoir trouver un compromis à défaut
l'assemblée aura le dernier mot
vous parlez de clivage tout al'air
autres la gauche à droite est débat sur
le nucléaire là vous avez là aussi un
grand débat oui c'est normal au fond
j'espère et je me réjouis que la
ministre de l'ecologie les annoncé que
le l'assemblée nationale reviendra sur
son texte de départ qui est totalement
essentiel en valeur la sphère du
réchauffement climatique
c'est la question majeure de notre
génération politique sinon on n'est pas
capable de résoudre ces problèmes
dans ces lois là à la conférence de
paris et dans les années qui viendront
le réchauffement aura lieu et les
désastres
qui vont avec humain écologique et
économique
alors il ya une autre décision qui vient
de tomber à l'instant
elle concerne le barrage le site de
sivens le conseil général du tarn vient
de décider de voter pour un site réduit
pour un projet de barrage réduit voilà
la décision
ils demandent aussi l'expulsion sans
délai des occupants un commentaire sur
cette décision
il faut regarder ce que ça veut dire
réduit puisque cissé réduits à presque
zéro ou si c'est le projet initial
reconfigurer avec trois bassins de même
taille ça change un peu tout mais que je
voudrais dire sur cette affaire c'est
que c'est pas normal qu'on en arrive là
parce que les questions qu'on pose et
les écologistes et les indices tels sont
très bonnes et on le voit d'ailleurs la
ministre a dit est un problème le projet
a été mal a été mal étudiés et en même
temps il doit y avoir une place pour
pour l'agriculture pour des retenues
d'eau et on doit être capable d'étudier
si ça bouleverse ou pas l'environnement
à fait d'accord donc moi qu'il faut
aussi repenser les méthodes de
concertation objectivement la
concertation soit était pas suffisamment
poussées soient était mal prises en
compte je pense qu'il faudra réfléchir à
une loi sur ce que ça veut dire que
quelque part la situation on la laisse
un petit peu pour air de ce côté là du
côté de sivens oui sur le fond surtout
parce qu'après quand il ya des
désaccords aussi sur les indices qui
occupent encore oui mais ça c'est
difficile vous savez gérer des questions
d'ordre public dans ces cas là où on
voit bien que les agriculteurs comme les
analystes ce qu'ils expriment c'est avec
leur coeur aussi radicaux d'un côté
comme de l'autre
ils défendent leur production à leur
capacité de production d'un côté les
réseaux de la rue aux missions ex aequo
et je crois que le ministre le premier
ministre et ministre de l'intérieur a
raison de dire que maintenant il faut
que la démocratie reprennent le dessus
le débat les actions ont permis de poser
le débat au plan national et que
maintenant on travaille de manière
démocratique sur les solutions parce
qu'on peut pas non plus tout le temps
s'opposer aux décisions des élus sinon
il ya plus de démocratie représentative
dans dans ce dans ce pays là donc mais
je vous dis encore une fois le fond du
problème et on l'a vu aussi sur notre
dame des landes soit capable de faire de
la concertation qui étudie tous les
problèmes parce qu'à chaque fois les
écologistes
alors on passe à mercredi christiane
taubira est à nouveau dans le
collimateur de la droite
un tract ambulants pour le fn ce sont
les propos d'un député ump gérald
darmanin sujet de christiane taubira
réaction immédiate de la garde des
sceaux ainsi que de manuel valls
mounir souci gérald darmanin ne
s'attendait pas à une telle riposte
après ses propos qualifiant la garde des
sceaux de traces d'ambulants pour le fn
le député du nord c'est d'abord attiré
les foudres du premier ministre hier
alors je vous le dis monsieur darmanin
les yeux dans les yeux ça n'est ni la
jeunesse ni la campagne électorale ni le
combat politique qui doit vous permettre
de tenir de tels propos et nous ne
permettrons jamais bon signe de soutien
les députés ps ont offert une
standing-ovation à christiane taubira la
cible préférée de l'opposition qui n'a
besoin de personne pour se défendre elle
considère les attaques du jeune député
comme rien de moins que des déchets de
la pensée humaine ce matin à la sortie
du conseil des ministres
elle a ajouté une salle aps franchement
je trouverais pitoyable
malgré son jeune âge peut-être même du
fait de son jeune âge sans doute à cause
de la déliquescence de son parti ils ont
soif en train à s'exprimer à tenir des
propos qu'ils ne soient pas être là et
éclairé par un idéal républicain pour
moi je trouverais ça pitoyable si je
rêve de la pitié a gaspillé des élus de
droite sont venus au secours de leur
collègue christian jacob estime que les
déclarations de christiane taubira sont
ignobles et dans un tweet xavier
bertrand juge que ces propos ne sont pas
digne d'un ministre de son côté gérald
darmanin persiste et signe et a reçu le
soutien unanime de tous sont partis dans
un communiqué publié par l'ump alors ses
propos de gérald darmanin petites
phrases pour faire du buzz ou propos
racistes selon vos genoux même pas les
qualifier mais moi j'ai envie de dire ça
suffit en permanence christiane taubira
est attaqué par la droite avec des
propos qui ont des relents nauséabonds à
chaque fois à la limite de du propos
racistes en effet en jouant sur les mots
sur les allusions sous les en
sous-entendant qu'il faut il faut
arrêter c'est un ministre de la
république qui fait bien son travail qui
le fait main main dans la main en ce qui
concerne les questions de sécurité avec
manuel valls puis avec bernard cazeneuve
qui a porté une magnifique loi du
mariage pour touche quoi l'art est aussi
ça que si un taux bien elle est très
forte il ya aussi ça derrière c'est
qu'ils ont jamais pardonné le brio avec
elle elle a porté ses toiles à son mais
nationale mais moi je dis ça suffit on
peut pas attaquer une ministre de la
république comme ça alors je remarque
jamais on va accueillir à présent notre
partenaire du figaro pour un décryptage
de l'actuelle à loupé du scan
bonjour rejoint et vous allez nous
reparler du livre de jean marc germain
bonjour jean marc germain vous avez donc
publié un livre il s'appelle tout avait
si bien commencé
ça veut dire que ça c'est en train de
mal évolué vous évoquez donc les
premiers jours du quinquennat françois
hollande le corps la gauche était unie
auréolé de toutes ses victoires
électorales a candidaté vous précisément
le basculement
le jour où vous vous êtes dit nous
socialistes on va dans le mur avec ce
quinquennat
les deux étapes j'ai raconte dans le
livre un certain de mécontentement mais
assez naturel la loi bancaire calais pas
assez loin le traité constitutionnel qui
était pas à renégocier mais le crédit
d'impôt compétitivité emploi sans
contreparties pour les entreprises
décembre 2012 ça c'était le premier coup
voilà et puis rebelote janvier 2014 où
on double la mise et toujours sans
contrepartie
moi j'ai dit oui pour aider les
entreprises mais si on demanderait en
échange ça fait du dividende est ce
qu'il faut demander comme efforts aux
français n'est pas acceptable et ne
fonctionne pas économiquement donc après
les municipales ont décidé effectivement
en tant que parlementaire de dire on va
usines et non seulement notre voie ce
qu'on a commencé à ferran mais de notre
vote pour que ça pète changé et elle va
macron c'est la goutte d'eau la loi
macron c'est d'une autre nature c'est à
dire qu elle s est nommé aux pratiques
tout le monde l'a dit le prétendant a
offert l'hilarante 9,3 et la loi du 6 et
pas la loi du siècle a dit le président
de la république donc ils bougent des
curseurs dans tous les sens dans le
temps on appelait ça des ddos des
différentes mesures fiscales mais sur
les principes il touche des choses qui
sont contraires à tout ce qu'on a
toujours défendu par ailleurs alors du
calme dimanche
mais il ya un autre élément par exemple
dont on n'a pas beaucoup parlé
aujourd'hui un grand groupe qui a
beaucoup d'argent quand il ferme une
entreprise il doit accompagner les
salariés et bien là on supprime ça vous
rendez compte de ce que ça veut dire
nous qui avons toujours dit les
entreprises doivent être responsables
quand elles ont les moyens de payer là
dans votre
étonnant voilà vous raconter une scène
assez amusante il faut le dire ça se
passe pour la conférence de presse de
françois hollande c'est en septembre
dernier et le chef d'état annonce à ce
moment là qu'en cas de rejet du vote de
confiance pour le nouveau gouvernement
valls un vote qui avait eu lieu deux
jours avant en cas de rejet il aurait
été prêt à appliquer la dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale
alors vous vous a pas un adversaire
résolu du droit de dissolution du
président et alors là vous prenez votre
smartphone et vous préparez un tweet
c'est un socialiste dit vous qui a
théorisé le coup d'état permanent c'est
un autre qui l'a expérimenté qui
l'expérimentent pardon aujourd'hui alors
ce tweet on l'a on la reconstituer parce
que où finalement vous l'avez pas à
publier vous avez considéré que c'était
peut-être trop caricatural est-ce que
après l'épisode de la du 49 3 de la loi
macron vous regrettez de ne pas avoir
publié ce tweet non parce que je crois
que quand on fait ce genre de tweets ont
fait des polémiques et on parle pas du
fond
en revanche le fond j'étais vraiment en
colère ce jour là parce que la
constitution a dit quoi elles disent y'a
pas la confiance
le président de la république doit
présenter soit le même gouvernement avec
un autre programme politique soit un
autre gouvernement
et là ça renverse totalement les choses
au fond ça revient à nier le parlement
ça veut dire soit vous vous soumettez à
tout ce que je souhaite avec l'exécutif
soit je vous dès mai et si on fait ça
non seulement le parlement n'existe plus
qu'un léger problème en démocratie mais
surtout le parlement j'explique ça dans
le livre c'est une valeur ajoutée normes
le travail qu'on fait et si on le
considère comme quantité négligeable il
n'y a plus aucun moment où entre l'idée
d'un exécutif qui est dans son rôle
quand il propose et ce qui devient
réalité ben y'a tout la consultation des
français à travers les parlementaires
qui est totalement vous allez vibrer
dans la république en moselle marc
sellam du coup d'état permanent
non je ne dirais pas d'ailleurs je les
pages les jamais dit mais c'est dans
votre livre g
jeudi en revanche que d'avoir prononcé
cette phrase était une erreur c'est bien
sur son droit d'utiliser la dissolution
mais d'en faire une règle comme il l'a
fait de cette manière là c'est à dire
attention pour l'avenir s'il n'y a pas
là confiants sur la dissolution ça ça va
pas parce qu'il faut vraiment qu'on se
dise et qu'on dédramatise au fond le
rôle d'un gouvernement c'est de trouver
une majorité à l'assemblée nationale sur
un texte jugeant le dimanche d'avoir
trouvé un accord sur le nombre de
dimanches travaillés parle donc dans une
dépêche afp publiée la semaine dernière
vous appelé à la constitution d'un
nouveau contrat de majorité avec les
radicaux de gauche avec les écologistes
vous dites si ça doit se traduire par un
nouveau gouvernement ça renforce la
chose vous dites même je n'ai jamais
suis personnellement les responsabilités
est ce que ça veut dire que vous êtes
prêt à rentrer dans un éventuel
gouvernement encadre magnon par exemple
après les élections départementales
j'ai été je les dis aussi responsables
des grandes lois du quinquennat
l'assemblée nationale était rapporteur
sur les emplois d'avenir j'étais aussi
rapporteur sur moi un peu plus polémique
était la loi de sécuriser son emploi
donc j'ai toujours été là pour
accompagner le gouvernement mais avec
une exigence se font d'être fidèle à ce
qu'on a promis à nos électeurs
et puis la deuxième moi je suis économie
c'est de faire ce que je pense je
n'aurais pas eu ma drogue
donc pour le pays donc je redis ce que
j'ai dit exactement la priorité c'est
qu'on ait un contrat de gouvernement qui
réunisse tous ceux qui ont porté
françois hollande c'est à dire les
écologistes l'ensemble de la gauche
le soutien peut-être sans participation
des communistes c'est ça la priorité
retour des verts oui je souhaite le
retour d hubert il faudra que ça
s'incarne dans un gouvernement
ensuite ira total ci se confesse me
convient ce que les aubrystes justement
peuvent cohabiter au sein d'un
gouvernement avec par exemple emmanuel
macron qui a qualifié les frondeurs de
foyers infectieux sont les mots très
forts est ce qu'on peut encore cohabiter
dans une dans une telle ambiance
écoutez je crois que manuel macron était
au ski quand il a prononcé ces phrases
on appelle ça une faute de carre ça
arrive quand on se laisse griser par la
vitesse donc je mets ça sur le compte de
son inexpérience mais faut pas prononcer
des mots comme ça en politique quand on
a des débats difficiles comme on a des
décisions difficiles à prendre pour la
france je crois que la première chose à
faire c'est de respecter les positions
des autres
il aurait dit moi je pense que c'est bon
pour la france mais je respecte les
positions de ceux qui sont pas d'accord
samar serait très bien aller et j'aurais
accepté dans ce cas de la halle
l'utilisation des 40 qu'il avait ce
terme technique il avait acquis un conte
de fées qui aurait pu virer au cauchemar
en situation irrégulière armando curie
devait quitter le territoire depuis
octobre dernier
dans ces conditions le sénat a d'abord
refusé de l'accueillir
bon je le président du sénat sont
explique j'ai examiné le dossier hier en
arrivant et j'ai pris la décision après
avoir informé le cabinet du ministre de
l'intérieur d'accueillir ce jeune parce
qu'il était le symbole d'une réussite
parce qu'ils étaient aussi portés par
des maîtres d'apprentissage et que les
meilleurs ouvriers de france porter un
certain nombre de valeurs
grâce à l'émotion suscitée armando a pu
bénéficier in extremis d'un titre de
séjour de trois mois et espère être
régularisés le sourire aux lèvres pour
la belle histoire d'armando mais des cas
comme avant mais il y en a des dizaines
en france qui ne sont pas médiatisés
cela faut leur donner des papiers à tous
à tous il ya des critères mais en
revanche il se passe des choses dont les
préfectures qui sont pas acceptables moi
j'en reçois dans mes permanences il
n'arrive même pas à prendre de rendez
vous je crois qu'il faut être très clair
faut accueillir tout ce qu'on peut
accueillir parce qu'on voit bien que ses
talents pour la france pour l'économie
pour l'économie française mais quand on
les accueille faut être capable de le
faire dans de bonnes conditions je sais
ça qui est difficile à trouver mais ce
qu'ils essaient de lancer manuel valls
mais qui pas encore sur le terrain c'est
que les règles soient claires les
dossiers soient étudiées rapidement on
va faire des progrès sur un autre sujet
qui est celui de l'asile et caen et que
ça se traduise dans la vie quotidienne
de ces gens qui vivent des situations
invraisemblables
on passe au jeudi les maires ont rendez
vous avec le premier ministre
l'association des maires de france
avaient rendez vous à matignon objectif
demander un gel de la baisse des
dotations aux collectivités pour seul
gain de cause ils ont obtenu un groupe
de travail un nouveau rendez vous en mai
prochain
écoutez à ce sujet leur président
françois baroin il a entendu c'est un
ancien élu local et le sens du dialogue
il nous a et nous sommes d'accord
là-dessus fixe un calendrier court c'est
à dire d'ici fin mai dans un groupe de
travail commun entre les services de
matignon et ceux des maires de france
pour avoir un diagnostic partagé et
trouver les meilleures réponses pour
préserver l'investissement et donc pour
préserver le rôle d'acteur économique
que nous jouons nous collectivités
alors jean marc jamas qu'en l'état
actuel des choses la hausse des impôts
locaux s'annonce inévitable
même la cour des comptes le dit il y
aura sans doute une hausse des impôts
locaux mais moi je soutiens totalement
la position de la mf qui est d'ailleurs
partagée à droite et à gauche on a vu le
président et vice-président à l'image et
je fais une proposition très simple qui
coûte pas un euro de plus cédé recevait
ya une baisse d'impôt qui a été prévu
pour les entreprises s'appelle la c3s la
cotisation des sociétés pour la sécurité
sociale
ça va faire cinq milliards ont leurs
oeuvres à la montée du front national ça
à voir aussi avec le fait que certaines
zones se sentent oubliés de la
république et dans les collectivités
locales parce que la proximité c'est
elle qui la font et si elles n'ont pas
les moyens de la faire
alors cette république française qui se
délite un peu faut pas exagérer non plus
va se déliter encore plus donc je crois
que c'est vraiment essentiel c'est
peut-être si j'avais une chose a demandé
au président de la république c'est de
reprendre cette proposition il ya 5
milliards qu'on peut faire basculer d'un
endroit à un autre et vous savez ce sera
un espèce de plan marshall pour les
territoires sera une grande force pour
la france ce sera la meilleure réponse
de long terme aux attentes à deux
pareillement vous aurez l'occasion de
lui parler c'est qu'en fait le tenace
mais moi aussi juste
frondeur le savez un sujet qui touche
les élus locaux comme vous êtes plutôt
exposition universelle ou plutôt
organisation des jo à paris ce que
j'arrive pas bien voir c'est si il faut
choisir parce que si on peut faire les
deux tant mieux mais ça coûte ça
défendre l'idée que les investissements
et les infrastructures pourront servir
aux deux à ce moment là faisons-le et
moi j'ai en tout cas beaucoup apprécié
la démarche de la maire de paray sur les
jeux olympiques et il faut pas se
tromper là dessus jean marc germain vous
emmener au cinéma c'est tout se débloque
c'est tisane fort c'est le nom du film
c'est aussi le pseudo qu'avait edouard
snowden ce film récompensé d'un oscar
surtout après les révélations de
l'ancien employé de la msa sur
l'espionnage mondial du gouvernement
américain et le séisme bien sûr qui a
suivi si mon mari a vu le film et vous
explique tout au plus près des douars
snowdon l'histoire est connue celle d'un
ancien informaticien de l' agence
nationale de sécurité américaines qui un
jour de juin 2013 décide de révéler
comment la nsa espionne les citoyens du
monde entier
ce que l'on ne savait pas en revanche
c'est que le désormais célèbre veillance
d'état qu'on a pu voir à ce moment là
elle a été révélée par ce lait de russie
où son autorisation de séjour a été
renouvelé pour trois ans edouard snowdon
a félicité la documentariste laura
poitras les citoyens en soutien de tous
qui permet d'assurer la sécurité d'un
territoire mais en revanche d'une
exigence absolue c'est qu' un contrôle
démocratique
or là il n'a pas eu lieu sur ces
questions là qu'on sache qui fait
comment et dans quelles limites ça veut
pas dire de suivre de chaque action des
services secrets mais d'en avoir un
contrôle absolu et une connaissance du
public sur ce qu'il faisait
l'occurence n'était pas le cas oui mais
ces pratiques perdurent en même temps
voit que big brother et une longue vie
devant lui oui mais par exemple que
depuis ce moment là les ministres du
gouvernement français ont été de
téléphone crypté par exemple voilà il ya
des mesures qui ont été prises même si
on pourra jamais
évitez les choses mais le fait qu'on ait
appris par exemple que les dirigeants
allemand français écouter et non
protégées c'était quelque chose de très
important pour la démocratie c'est pas
admissible 500 une démocratie un
scandale oui maintenant un scandale
international single à berkane a été
écoutée doute l'eau était aussi plané
sur chef d'état alors là d'un jour oui
bien sûr il faut qu'on se protège contre
ça c'est un souveraineté qui en cause
merci beaucoup jean marc germain d'avoir
été l'invité de la terre sont tombés la
semaine prochaine la semaine prochaine
même lieu même heure merci à tous de
votre fidélité et rester avec nous sa
chaîne parlementaire lcp public sénat
très bonne suite du programme
irlandaise la bataille de l'avortement
c'est notre documentaire ce sera aussi
d'autres débats et si le droit arrivé
j'ai était plus fragile qu'on